besoin de votre expertise je le disais
mais avant ça tout simplement votre
votre sentiment ce soir
mais ce que je disais c'est que c'est
une douleur une douleur aiguë parce que
chaque enfant évidemment a le droit de
vivre ça coule de source et chaque
enfant a le droit d'avoir un cadre
scolaire
où il peut avoir ses apprentissages
faire sa vie dans les dans les
meilleures dans les meilleures
conditions et c'est douloureux ce ce cas
comme tous les autres il est extrêmement
douloureux parce qu'il est tout en début
d'année
généralement vous avez ce qu'on appelle
parfois dans dans la saison du
harcèlement scolaire qui commence plutôt
à la Toussaint au bout de deux mois là
c'est tout de suite c'est c'est en plus
d'un élève qui avait changé
d'établissement donc ça ça veut dire
plein de choses ça veut dire et c'est un
premier point que moi je je veux qu'on
travaille qu'on aille plus loin et je
sais que le ministre que que qui m'a
déjà consulté qu'on a déjà travaillé
ensemble et je crois qu'il faut revoir
la façon dont la parole est écouté celle
de l'enfant
et l'enquête dira comment ça s'est passé
mais je crois qu'on doit on a trop
d'enfants qui parfois ou trop de parents
qui nous disent à l'institution bouge
pas il y a pas de réaction voilà alors
qu'il y en a mais je crois qu'il faut
qu'on montre un niveau d'empathie un
niveau d'écoute absolue à chaque fois
qu'un enfant vient voir un adulte pour
lui dire qu'il a qu'il a le qu'il est
harcelé c'est voilà ça c'est un premier
point mais mais il y en a d'autres et on
peut développer évidemment je alors
premier point je crois pas qu'on soit
particulièrement en retard par rapport
aux autres pays enfin c'est toujours un
sujet on a l'impression de qu'on est à
la traîne il y a des actions qui ont été
prises il y a des méthodes et vous
parler de la méthode de la préoccupation
partagée qui est une bonne méthode pour
faire de la prévention et pour résoudre
les conflits naissants maintenant moi
j'ai j'ai une conviction c'est qu'il
faut qu'on travaille sur
l'accompagnement des victimes quand les
quand les situations se sont installées
et que les situations sont douloureuses
pour les pour les pour les victimes la
méthode de la préoccupation partagée
elle est très très bonne je le redis
pour faire de la prévention et
maintenant dans le cadre de la loi qu'on
a voté le 2 mars 2022
il y a une obligation de moyens dans
chacun des établissements et chacun des
établissements de notre pays doit mettre
en place des plans de prévention et
d'accompagnement mais je pense qu'il
faut qu'on muscle tout ça il faut qu'on
mette des moyens supplémentaires et
surtout c'est qu'il faut que dans ce
pays on fasse une première grande étude
pour une étude de victimisation globale
pour connaître l'ampleur du phénomène on
le connaît par ces par ces phénomènes de
suicide et à chaque fois ils reviennent
sur la table par ces phénomènes de
suicide mais je pense qu'il faut aussi
qu'on prenne le temps d'avoir des
données très précises pour analyser ce
phénomènes et pour que les sciences
cognitives les pédagogues les
scientifiques développent aussi des des
méthodes de d'accompagnement des
victimes quand vous dites quand vous
dites
l'ampleur du phénomène il y a des
chiffres au fait
alors il y a des chiffres mais c'est des
chiffres qui sont assez anciens qui sont
vous voyez moi j'avais dans mon rapport
gouvernemental il y a deux ans j'avais
un chiffre qui était de dire presque cet
enfant
on disait 700 000 700 000 enfants mais
tout ça et tout ça et je pense vraiment
700 000 enfants harcelés voilà c'est
énorme sur 700 000 en France
le bassin global
voilà sur la cohort d'une année d'une
année scolaire
mais ça fait voilà mais tout ça il faut
qu'on l'objectif encore plus et moi
c'est une des propositions que j'ai fait
au ministre c'est d'avoir une grande
étude de victimisation mais ce sera pas
suffisant évidemment ne nous cachons pas
derrière une étude supplémentaire il y
en a eu déjà suffisamment et on connaît
le phénomène mais ça va nous permettre
aussi de de cibler il y a des âges qui
sont délicats des moments dans la vie de
l'apprentissage qui sont délicat tout ça
il faut qu'on continue à avancer et il
faut qu'on ait aussi une grande
réflexion et le ministre on a parlé sur
une chaîne concurrente chez vous sur sur
la mise en place d'une école de
l'empathie c'est-à-dire que les valeurs
de camaraderie les valeurs d'écoute de
l'autre les valeurs de
d'apprécier les différences de l'autre
elles doivent être aussi au cœur du
projet éducatif de notre pays ça doit
passer par là ça c'est pour la
prévention
j'ai envie de dire et et on a le volet
accompagnement je le redis il faut qu'on
ait des méthodes des grilles
accompagnement très très fortes et et
très efficace et qui donne
il donne pas le sentiment qui donne la
conviction à l'enfant et aux familles
quels sont écoutées et qu'elles sont
vraiment que leur leur douleur est prise
en compte et c'est peut-être parfois un
petit peu ce qui manque rapidement
l'annonce sur les réseaux sociaux et ce
qu'on peut faire selon vous
sur les réseaux sociaux de le constat il
est là c'est que et moi je l'ai souvent
dit c'est que c'est plus de répit pour
l'enfant et quand il rentre dans son
cocon familial il continue à être
harcelé ce qu'il faut faire sur les
réseaux sociaux on va travailler dans le
cadre de la loi c'est de sécurisation et
régulation du numérique là qu'on est en
train de faire sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs ils seront ils seront sans
doute pas suffisants je pense qu'il y a
un travail aussi à faire sur la
parentalité c'est à dire que les parents
doivent responsabiliser leurs enfants
sur les réseaux sociaux quand ils leur
confie un téléphone portable il leur
confie un super boutique de
sociabilisation de liens avec les autres
et même de pédagogie mais leur conflit
aussi une arme envers eux et envers les
autres et donc la parentalité il faut
qu'on ait un grand travail
d'accompagnement de la parentalité ça me
semble ça me semble important et et
ensuite sur ce que sur ce que je vous
disais sur le sur la loi la loi elle
peut pas tout la loi elle donne un cadre
il faut quand même rappeler que avant de
loi il n'y avait pas d'obligation de
moyens dans les écoles sur le sujet et
il y avait même pas de mots harcèlement
scolaires ni dans le code de l'éducation
ni dans le code pénal donc déjà on a
défini un interdit et c'est maintenant
il faut que la puissance publique
respecte la définition de cette interdit
en mettant en place des politiques
publiques et c'est des politiques
publiques qui doivent être massives et
sur lequel on doit déployer encore plus
de moyens et j'espère que ça sera une
des un des axes de travail évidemment de
Gabriel attelage en tout cas moi c'est
je lui encourage et on discute ensemble
on a sur les sur ce sujet